girls go to college to get more
knowledge
boys go to jupiter to get more stupider
ticktock the absolute state of humanity
right now i did a video last week
mentioning that trolls have been
starting to appear on tick tock
making a blank face to a serious topic
or
making an epic silly dance while someone
says that they lost their mother
and such and so
and then when i realized he didn't
i felt so stupid oh
he did not just hit her with it now that
has just blown up completely
and it's amazing let's go through
some of the epic tick tock trolling guys
let's just jump into it you said you're
in love with me
guys say a lot of things grace wait
you're in love with me i know you're in
love with me
oh that's so sad
[Music]
that's right that girl thought some
stranger was gonna add in some cute
lil oh i love you instead he kicked her
in the face
that was epic
[Music]
why why i still have no answer to my
question
why do all these kids record this to
begin with i'd say
things are going pretty well for me on
here thank you
tic-tac i'm on the cover of a cringe
compilation
i'm moving to l.a to become a famous
tech talker damn the next is logan paul
everybody we found him you know they
the paul brothers people don't know they
started on vine
but i think in a way we should be
thankful to tick-tock because
tick-tock saved us from musicality
emigrating into youtube it's good that
we have it in one spot
so we know where to send the nukes i
literally want to get
out of my body and go somewhere else
no guys i cannot tell you enough how
important it is to love yourself
love your body and who you are and find
that inner strength
and show it you can also be beautiful
what a great message everybody if your
abs look like
a poor drawing of peter griffin then
that's okay
in case it wasn't obvious in tik tok you
can make a reply i don't know what it's
called it called something else
but how do you do fellow kids i don't
know what you call it and that's what
led to this tick-tock trolling
sometimes they just push it uh to the
next level like this oh my god
some of the trollings are just bad i'll
i'll say that but some of them damn
a plus a plus hi take two steps forward
if you're amazing now you better have
taken two steps forward
because you are wonderful
and beautiful and just if you have a gun
behind
like a knife manny's back what is he
going to do i don't trust this man this
reminds me of those vines where
the guy just been like you're so
beautiful
oh my god ah so to all those who think i
was just bluffing about telling the kids
parents
i wasn't i actually sent them a message
telling them their parents what their
kids are doing
oh snap they're on two ways there's his
mother as well
it's amazing so i need to know something
why do girls these days have to dress
half-naked
i mean didn't your mama teach you to
cover up your breasts
girls keep it classy not trashy
you can't get a good man any other way
why are moms using tick tock
why is anyone using tick tock speaking
of tick tock
here's a tick tock ad that's right
everybody you make a video about tick
tock
tick tock advertisement through google
it's just been like
we're gonna pull an ad on that it
doesn't matter if you're making fun of
it or if you're trash talking it
put a tick tock ad in there every tweet
i got from last video was just like i
got a tick tick-tock ad
on this video you know what maybe i can
cheat the sister
what if i just i want to get those
premium ads right
what if i just start saying like
expensive car
incredible jewelry i just bought a rolex
and so should you
buy an expensive watch expensive
luxurious incredible richness
watches and cars hopefully you got an
amazing ad there
if it's not a premium ad i'm gonna be so
jittery bullied
oh my god i love these the ones that are
just
like what's the original video it's just
some kid making a rhyme
knowledge boys go to jupiter to get more
stupider
oh she did not just say they go to
jupiter to get more stupider
feminists if you don't like furries go
away
if you don't like furries go away i've
got a lot to do not any time for you
if you don't like furries go
away now i'm not going anywhere
because no animal can tell me what to do
you know what i eat for breakfast
dogs you guys want to see a magic trick
i want to pull this out of my head
really quick
oh my god it's this again knowledge boys
go to jupiter to get
more stupider
[Music]
can we just have a thank you side for uh
editing out all the copyrighted material
of this video
appreciation thank you brad too is it
cool if i bring my sister no dude it's
bro time
[Music]
yeah she can
uh come only my friend sister looked
that attractive when i was younger god
damn it
it's not fair she runs like a jeans
corset
like what what even is that if you don't
like furries go away
if you don't like furries go away i've
got a lot to do not
any time for you if you don't like
furries
go away now
this is so sad girls go to college to
get
more knowledge both go to jupiter to get
more stupider
how long is it gonna go on the parents
have started to notice this how
kids are just making fun of kids on this
site and of course the responses
i think there needs to be a parental
contact
on tick-tock because obviously some of
these parents don't know what their
ten-year-olds are doing
and i mean some of these screen names
thought 69
what's the thought she must be trolling
i don't believe that you don't just go
969 what's a thought
what the frick guys i was so you guys
so you guys if you want a shout out you
just need to do a do it with me then i
shout you out
what is happening i feel so old
i never felt this old as when i look at
these tick tock videos
you know i thought it would just be one
trend with that good boys like that
guys already and i thought we would be
done
but it just keeps going and it's
epically tick-tock i love it
you know what i never thought i would
say that i actually never thought i
would say that
if you are under the age of 18 years old
do not get on my profile do not do duets
with my profile videos
do not even look at my profile keep
moving why are you
a over 18 and on tick tock that's the
appropriate question here
all right more for dancing after 40.
this is the fortnight height dance
i'm gonna turn sideways so you can see
you're gonna kick your leg
you're gonna pump your arm and then
you're gonna move it down low ready
don't let the kids intimidate you that's
the thing why are all these adults on
there
i'm stuck in between these kids and
these adults
what am i what am i supposed to be where
do i belong fellow kids and adults guys
comment thanos if you made it to the end
these kids must be stopped
and adults as well thank you very much i
hope this
tick-tock cringe thing keeps going god
bless everyone
i'm pewdiepie bro fist out
[Music]
you